hi I'm Casey and I'm going to explain
how your message knows where to go each
website on the internet is associated
with a unique IP address this is
something like 1887 0 36 it consists of
four numbers separated by decimal points
each between 0 and 255 each IP address
is associated with the host name so this
is something like math MIT edu now when
you type math at mit.edu into your web
browser your web browser uses a tool
called the domain name system or dns to
look up the associated IP address and
dns works just like a giant foam book
which maps host names to IP addresses
which we use because they're easier for
us to remember so say that this is your
computer and you've just typed math that
mit.edu into your web browser your
computer will then forward this request
along to a router and a router is just a
computer which forwards information
between nodes on the internet and this
router will forward the information
along to other routers this process will
continue until it reaches a router which
knows how to reach the end destination I
which point it will forward it there
so that's how your information knows to
get from where you are to your end
destination